Charlotte is in Colorado and says I've
got a question in regard to 25% rule for
home mortgage we live in Steamboat
Springs where property prices are high
only condos will be in our price range
should the HOA fees be included in the
25% HOA dues are very high here due to
the high cost of snow removal sometimes
as high as $350 a month okay here's the
situation the whole thing of saying
don't put more than 25 percent of your
take-home pay into a house payment on a
15-year fixed-rate mortgage is so that
you don't get house poor I grew up in
the real estate business I got my real
estate license in 1978 I'm old I have
seen a lot of people do a lot of stupid
stuff with real estate and I've seen a
lot of people make a lot of money in
real estate you know who makes money in
real estate people that don't get
themselves in a position that they're
forced to sell it real estate that sells
fast is known as cheap it's a good buy
from me because I'm gonna buy it from
somebody's in trouble so you can kind of
back in go well you know I live in New
York or Steamboat Springs there's snow
or you know it's is there a is there do
I get a pass on math no you don't get a
pass on math math works everywhere
exactly the same and so if you don't
make enough to live in an area where the
real estate is expensive that means you
don't make enough to live in an area
where the real estate is expensive
I live in Williamson County in Tennessee
it's the wealthiest County in the state
it's the eleventh wealthiest County in
the nation it's absurd the average house
price in our county is double any other
county in the state cray cray
I mean it's nuts out here it's just a
little suburban bubble outside of
Nashville there's those types of sea
areas all over America and I can't
afford to live in Williamson County
maybe not maybe not yet to make more to
live there I can afford to live in
Manhattan
probably not pretty much got to make six
figures to live on the island darlin so
the most expensive real estate on the
planet
Orange County Manhattan Miami Beach
Tokyo London these are all right
Singapore they're all right there
together and you just have to make a lot
of money live there and so I get this
question all the time well do I live in
California well maybe you don't anymore
or maybe you're gonna move to a
different part of California but you're
probably not gonna live in frickin
Laguna Beach you know if you're making
forty five thousand dollars a year the
numbers don't work sorry you don't get a
pass on math so you can include the HOV
fees you can talk about snow you can not
talk about that but at the end of the
day the question is not whether my 25
percent works or whether you what you
include in the 25 percent the question
is after you pay get through paying for
your house are you broke and when you
take out a house payment HOA fees piti
principal interest taxes and in Texas
Maori or high yeah well I understand you
live in one of those areas where stupid
people have run up the tax base and then
wonder why everybody left and so that
that's what's going on you know and so
you got to ask yourself do I fit in here
but when you add it all together and
then you are finished paying for your
housing are you broke that's called
house poor and when you get much over
30% on that you start to get
the trouble 30% of your take-home pay
now a mortgage company on a thirty-year
adjustable rate will qualify you for
about twice as much as you can actually
afford but you can't do anything else so
after you pay your payment when your
kids are gonna be skinny please don't
talk to me about vacations please don't
talk to me about saving for your kids
college
please don't wonder why you're not able
to fund your retirement when you've got
your house strangling strangling you I
love real estate owning your own home
and getting it paid for is one of the
two primary pieces of financial data
that will lead you to being a
millionaire owning real estate is
absolutely vital for your financial
future but owning it the wrong way will
destroy your life biting off more than
you can chew and you choke on it
will destroy your life so Real Estate's
a two-edged sword Oh everyone should buy
real estate real estate is the answer
when poor people don't have access to
real estate when broke people can't buy
real estate we need policy change
there's systemic problems with our way
of life capitalism isn't working no
you're full of crap and you just can't
do math because when a whole bunch of
broke people buy houses you know what
happens they securitize that stupidity
and selling and hedge funds oh wait then
they take it to the main market oh wait
you can almost destroy the entire way of
life known as the United States you know
what happened in 2008 when a whole bunch
of broke people bought houses that
couldn't afford houses and put them on
mortgages and overpaid for them and they
securitize that crap meaning they bundle
the mortgages together and sell them as
Fannie Mae blocks in bonds and then they
all failed well shock broke people buy
houses it makes them broker that's why
they call them mortgage brokers don't do
it I love real estate I want you to get
a house it's a key part of you becoming
wealthy but when you rationalize your
butt off and think map done
try to find a way that I can I can
somehow figure out a way that I'm going
to overpay for this and it's gonna be
okay because my situation we have snow
that's just bogus doesn't work it's like
the guy who says I gotta have a full
wheel drive truck for snow it snows once
a year you gonna have a four-wheel-drive
truck so you go $40,000 in debt to drive
once a year then this is just
rationalization so no you count
everything not you don't count the
utilities but what does it cost for you
to own this property and is that gonna
own you that's the question you have to
answer the rule of thumb we use is you
shouldn't have more than about 25% of
your income your take-home pay going
towards that then that leaves room and
the other 75% to buy stuff like food
college funds retiring with dignity
saving up and paying cash for the next
car so it's not in debt saving up and
paying cash for the next couch so it's
not in debt saving up and paying cash
for your little vacation so it's not in
debt and when you have so much debt on
your house that you have no margin no
disposable income in your budget all the
other stuff starts turning into debt and
this snowballs and falls down on your
head no pun intended so check it out
folks we've got to use common sense if
you think you got house fever and you're
getting ready do something stupid with a
house they'll take a cold shower they'll
help you get over the house fever